welcome to this video playing blitz 5
minute against tactic with tactical
zoton midway G am I right yeah yeah I am
right
c4 ok let's play something solid I very
often play the b6 line but let's do a
really solid setup the symmetrical it's
one of the most reliable ways to play
this is black you pretty much equalize
of the bed and lots of lines here it's
actually not that solid I'm trying to do
something here with age 5 if he allows
it why not
and so I'm getting rid of this bishop
here that's not bad long castles is the
gambling man's move but it really looks
it looks bad or is H form it's this may
be possible or is this crazy giving up
giving up with 97 this material probably
it is crazy right I should go back yeah
probably H 5 wasn't the most successful
endeavor ever but it's not it's not
hurting me a lot really really isn't
what is his plan now maybe Bishop c3 is
a booth seems he really is a little bit
concerned down Knight f6 probably Bishop
c3 yeah maybe I should do that just get
get developed is there something else
probably not just normally moves the
reason why this is somewhat toothless
for widest that he is not ever achieving
deform getting something really
substantial going in the center and the
best that very often white can do in
this kind of symmetrical structures with
d3 g3 is to get in before which he which
he has accomplished I mean but it's it's
still kind of yeah not much but now this
is really weird have this kind of this
Knight dance here can you even play e5
if I want just not bad
not not quite getting what he's doing
with those nights but okay let's just go
b6 strengthening move I can push them
back whenever I want I also have 95 it's
not bad actually in 95 but I can also go
for defy like taking on before play d5
yeah maybe maybe I'm not justice ditches
prepared e5 that's good central plain so
or d5 takes Knight takes Knight takes
Queen takes it's definitely not bad for
me now come on let's just let's just go
for it especially considering that at
the moment he's got this unprotected
bishop on d2 might be a pretty good
pretty good time to get it in now I'm
like him that's good
yeah Quinn takes I guess 95 was one idea
but it's not threatening that much I can
just recapture though keeping the
pressure on d3 on
Jim simply taking on d3 is probably not
bad but I was thinking that this is
maybe better trying to take with the
night
mmm maybe even f6 is a threat but it
looks can move 94 probably f6 is
probably not a threat but just d3 is
it's quite substantial if I can take it
would be nice okay so just counter
taking him I can't take it it's not like
I cannot let's take it
it's even the possible exchange
sacrifice that was on okay cheeks or
Luke cheeks I'm not sure and then a
little bit down on time so I should just
play and figure it out later
let's say yeah take it and Bishop FA
that's kind of kind of passive maybe
maybe this one now it's got ninety four
it's probably just the same
yeah I just have a pawn Isis got some
activity this is not so easy maybe I
should have played it somewhat
differently it is not so easy at all
it's got active it's got really active
pieces I'm not quite sure how I should
have played it but he I'm not better
time warning weird yeah I'm giving up
the pawn for counter play and was a
totally one-sided game and now I'm in
trouble
unbelievable and he was totally
outplayed just check what what did I do
wrong here really strange check check
I definitely cannot play for a win and
this is I'm just trying to draw him game
no not much not much else
check I think you for now
alright ok from me again 23 seconds
kimby three funny trick check
yeah yeah okay I wanted to resign resign
I wrote a nervous game yeah and how am i
how did I end up with this I mean it was
just totally totally outlet and I should
just win this endgame somehow why didn't
I do that I even have the better minor
piece here how did I end up in this in
this problem Shirley just by by doing
imprecise tactical moves it's just a
matter of a little bit of precision so
that he does not get this activity which
I allowed I mean played really played it
badly I mean okay the end position was
again okay and so on but it's it's not
the problem I mean I should just just
not get into any trouble here after this
kind of course of the game okay I took
with the rook and maybe Kree takes this
better and it's it's possible like this
ideas now we have the C pawn supported
by the bishop so I'm just very clearly
better the only thing that really can
happen is what happened in the game we
get the knight to the c-4 locating
square and this gets this gets tricky
maybe we should be to us the key I don't
know I never looked at this move and
this is just so easy it's just much much
much easier
the thing is that I mean he has to find
this first as a saving move otherwise
I'm winning directly this pawn and here
I just get this in this is a big
difference here because this is now very
safely protected and then I can get get
to get my king er player five and and
I'm really quite clearly in command
this is not this is not the same thing
now is blockading I mean I probably lost
some time here but yeah it is tricky
already it is tricky already because
he's got this activity that he
definitely has compensation from the can
check well it can't continued and around
here I'm starting to to be better again
and probably shouldn't definitely
shouldn't lose I mean what for draw for
example I can just take here of course
but as I wanted to try on and okay the
poorest is not worth very much it's
probably really just said wrong but i
blundered blundered the rook and at the
rupiah yeah should never lose this
position of course okay well thanks for
watching